i don't want to go upstairs with dude
no i don't i don't want to film with you
bro
okay so if we're going to go upstairs
i'll go up we'll go upstairs but i don't
want let's do it up there what did this
become the debris show it's okay
spackles no problem i'm gonna knock him
out if you bring him up no you're not
the sparkle beef continues as the rest
of the cast looks on in confusion about
why jabri is continuing to pick a fight
with patrick's brother john we're all
invited here including i just don't want
to get into it with him you know what i
mean well listen it's not about you so
okay chilling should i just hit him
no
patrick's response sounds like he knows
his brother would really do it it was
the last no
should i just hit him
no
no i just don't know what he's doing i
don't care who you put sparkles and who
would have thought john who would create
the tagline of the season it's okay
sparkles that's what you say when
someone is doing the absolute most okay
sparkles
go ahead shine on over there if
somebody's toxic in your life you are
removed from my life i'm benching you
when you do the work and you get better
maybe i'll bring you back into my
starting fight but right now you're
benched email me
we'll get into jabri's interesting
explanation for sparking up the sparkles
beef and how it gets subtle for now plus
you don't think below
they're not going to work out
i hope they do but i don't think they
will my gut's usually right
after he calls himself prophesying that
ari and benny's relationship is not
going to last jabrie makes the same
prediction for bilal and shaida because
i can see the future and speaking of
bilal he's coming to terms with his
flaws after all the criticism he's
received
here i am just thinking i'm this good
guy but it seems like
everybody sees it different you know
and although shada does her best to try
to comfort him
i do know bilal is an amazing person
like i will not travel all this way
almost 3 000 miles to marry someone that
i think is not fit to be a husband the
concerns she has about their future
together start to overwhelm her
but if i stay silent it could turn out
to be like your last marriage
[Music]
season 9 has been a bumpy ride let's get
into it
hey 90 day fans fam it's melisia before
we get into jabrie and john
it is not lost on me that some of you
think i have a crush on balau or feel
some type of way about chida
let's not be ridiculous here okay
i know this is fun and games for y'all
but
this is a job for me i'm at work
literally i'm taking my lunch break
after this your girl is hungry
i know we have a good time and i enjoy
putting these recaps together for you
but just know it is never that deep for
me okay
let's keep it respectful
that's all i ask
also y'all at the end of this week's
episode eve reveals that following the
tell-all
she found out muhammad was texting
another woman he met online
crossing all types of lines
read that text message the woman said i
can't wait to meet you and he said quote
i'll go to the attorney right after i
get the green card
i mean
i'm shocked but i'm not shocked
he also called himself sexting the woman
oh my god he chose to spend his time
focused on
starting other relationships engaging
activity he a married man should not be
engaging in
and of course it ends with muhammad in
tears saying he's going to try to fix
things with eve
why do they always cry after the fact i
know i did wrong all i can do now is
saying story to my wife and i promised
her that will never happen again
eve says she doesn't know what the
future holds so
i'm not sure what that means
all right moving on jabrie what do you
think your family and friends are
jealous of we look good together
we shine
quick refresh on part one of the talal
jabri was the center of attention and it
wasn't just because of his outfit
on top of his hot takes toward ari and
benny
y'all fake y'all ain't gonna work out
perfect
he randomly butted into john's
conversation with dais and patrick about
their family issues
and okay sparkles
was born
you drunk right now
you're free drunk yeah how many beers
you drank this morning bro okay man i
had six last night damn something like
you made the 12 pack this morning oh man
your sparkles are blinding me though bro
man you know what i'm saying i'm trying
to i don't know if i can focus something
shining off your head boy you're gonna
get to see that you happy you don't have
a happy family
you won't
okay spackles
part two of the tell-all picks back up
with jabri and john arguing on stage
you're talking about your brother's girl
right now come on you feel me bro
this is this is your this is gonna be
look at that that's look at your brother
he's happy for him he's happy he's going
to be a great father caisse is going to
be a great mother john is like yeah
i want him to be
he's going to be a great father
aisa is going to be a great mother you
lonely at home drinking six packs of
beer playing video games
chill that's
it sounds like you're dimming lights
debris
if you see that someone else's light
isn't lit why not try to light it why
try to kill their spirit even more
i don't know about you but i don't get
the gist that jon isn't happy for his
brother and thyes he might have his
issues he needs to work through but i
believe he does want to see patrick do
well at the end of the day and when it
comes to jabri's hot take
it's one thing to have an opinion about
a person or situation but when you speak
as if your opinion is the absolute truth
you happy you don't have a happy family
you won't when you don't know that
person or their situation personally
in my eyes that's when it becomes a
problem
erica says it best
the man that
knows that he knows nothing at all
[Applause]
okay i think we need a break
all right collect your people
what's up bro what's up bro it's good to
see you good to see you
a lot of times even somebody can be an
ass or be a joke but you see there's
good to them too and he's a nice person
he loves his brother and yeah he'd
probably be a fun uncle
i am here for that laugh time
why is jabrie so upset
that's what i'm saying dude that's a
that's a guy who gets a little looks
like
his panties in a bunch you know he likes
it he likes to spit stuff but he can't
take stuff back you know that type of
thing
some people are soft bro
i don't know what sparkles things are i
can't remember my rainy handy and
getting back up
drop spackles right on the ground
glitter goes everywhere fast forward to
when the cast break is wrapping up
backstage just when you think things are
cooling off jabri pulls out the diva
card or
should i say the devo card
and it looks like it catches everyone by
surprise
i guess we gotta get you back upstairs
i don't want i don't want to go upstairs
with dude
no i don't i don't want to film with you
bro
okay
patrick is like sticks and stones may
break my bones but words will never hurt
me
okay
if we're going to go upstairs i'll go
off we'll go upstairs but i don't want
let's do it up there it's okay spackles
no problem i'm gonna knock him out if
you bring him up no you're not
no you're not that's not how that story
ends no no no no no no i can tell you
that's not how the energy throw off this
whole i wish i could read shot in
emily's minds right now they're looking
like what is going on
if jon's energy is throwing everything
off why is jabri the only one with the
problem
somebody had to tell him to act up at
the tell-all
at this point i hope they did
also the way jabrie is turning up makes
you wonder
did they cut something out of the actual
episode that aired
are we missing something are you crying
nah i'm crying it sounds like you're
crying i don't want you i don't want it
to escalate to that point you know what
i
mean
we're all invited here including i just
don't want to get into it with him you
know what i mean
welp eve you tried
and you don't want to get into it with
him
that's got self-control you don't have
to i want to know what miona is thinking
because she's not saying a thing just
sitting pretty
well if you're going to bring it bro you
got to take it yes you know what i'm
saying everything you've given you're
going to be the one taking a lot i don't
think so you've already taken a lot of
energy from your people and i don't like
to see that
so jabrie is claiming he's going after
john in this way because he doesn't like
the way john interferes in thyes and
patrick's relationship
none of his business but
he's making it his business
this is my thing
i get that jabri is a passionate guy
but if you don't like the way john
interferes in his brother's relationship
and you actually want to help
why not talk to him in a way where he
could receive what you're saying
instead of dishing out threats and
basically calling him a drunk
you drunk right now now that's if you
really want to help diesel patrick
because i doubt cursing out john is
going to change a thing
maybe having a sensible conversation
would be more effective so you've
already taken a lot of energy from your
people and i don't like to see that
well listen it's not about you so okay
chilling so yeah i know you think you
decided to
i've seen you in action with your
boyfriend flashback
should i just hit him oh
and that's all respect to you patrick
that's all respect to you
threatening his brother who he adores
who helped raise him
is respect
how
sometimes people need a little smack you
know
this all respects you i just don't
i don't care who you with sparkles
i still want to talk to john
okay i know i said i wasn't really
feeling kenny and tim being commentators
in part one but i like the role they
play in part two they get out of those
chairs and go talk to the cast backstage
it's cool it adds to the conversation
were you surprised out of all of them
the paisley pastel cowboys the one that
went for you
hazel were your sparkles by the way i
guess they listened to jabrie's wishes
because john didn't end up back on stage
with everyone else
it's either they listened or his segment
is just over
he came for him he died cause i came out
and he's like this uh he's already drunk
six-pack or something like this well for
the first time i even had beer i woke up
at eight seconds oh we were wondering he
might be drunk no no i woke up at 6 50.
this is his personality
this is normal john meanwhile jabrie is
on set calling john a bully
and thaies is just grateful someone is
telling john to back up
what went on during that break
i don't like how that dude was talking
to tais and his brother man that's
that's that's crazy to me
at least someone say something
when i see people like how john was
treating them that brings me back to
where i was at in south dakota where you
know kids were bullying me and making
fun of me for being different or being
out there saying disrespectful stuff
that's some trailer trash that's what we
call it in america so that gets under my
skin when i see people belligerent but
not only belligerent just disrespectful
to people
am i tripping
i'm not tripping hold on let me let me
take a step back
i'm only human so i have my feelings and
it is my job to share my opinion but
what i do not want this to become and
this is honestly out of my control
because this is the internet but my
intention is not for this to become a
bash debris fest
that is never my goal when talking about
any 90 day cast member i don't care if
you're the worst of the worst
at the heart of it all
my goal is always to try to find ways we
as viewers can use what they go through
to reflect on our own lives that being
said
i think jabri is hammering home how
important self-awareness is
sometimes we can be so wrapped up in our
emotions that we're blind to the fact
that we're dishing out the same energy
we say we don't like or don't want to
receive
also something to note jabrie reveals
this episode that he hasn't seen his mom
since he left south dakota to marry
myona six months ago
and it seemed as if they had a pretty
close relationship before he married
miona so
maybe all this hostility has to do with
the fact that
he needs some mama's hug
or
he's not as happy as he thinks that's
some trailer trash that's what we call
it in america so that gets under my skin
when i see people belligerent but not
only belligerent just disrespectful to
people patrick does it not bother you to
hear someone call your brother trailer
josh
they from the trailer park he from a
trailer but look what his brother's
doing taking care of being a man you
know what i'm saying pay for everything
keep doing all that and he gonna sit
here drinking beers at his house making
fun of and belittling him i don't care
if that's your brother your dad your
sister your mom if somebody's toxic in
your life you are removed from my life
i'm benching you when you do the work
and you get better maybe i'll bring you
back into my starting fight but right
now you're benched email me
more power to you miona more power to
you girl that's all i'ma say if you
don't like people bullying others you
know like you were bullying me before
like you were picking on our
relationship like you don't always see
all the other things that go on so like
that could be hurtful what you said i
wasn't trying to pick on you
i was trying to say hey he's got a lot
of potential you should uplift him but
that's not what was said
emily also gives her take on the antics
backstage
who got under your skin who got under my
i feel like debris didn't make any sense
like why did he attack john he was going
after john the moment he came out he's
like you're an alcoholic you're wasted
right now i'm like
okay shut up for one it's getting too
intense well following jabrie's back and
forth with ari and john
he tells shaida and bilal what he thinks
about them
so debris of everybody here you think
the two that won't last are ari and
benny yeah emblem
no i think they have a better chance if
she can start being so jealous and
possessive and they got a kid together
you think that they have the least the
least amount of chance absolutely
below
i tend not to speak about what i don't
know below can we get a little more than
that
honestly it's not even about debris
being right or wrong he could be right
but i don't think it's wise to try to
predict the demise of someone else's
relationship when you don't know what's
going to happen to yours
life has a funny way of humbling you i
would be a little scared i ain't gonna
lie we've been apart for so long i'm
like let's enjoy each other for a little
bit
jabrie's prediction about shaida and
bilal comes up after sean asked them for
an update on their pregnancy journey and
i will say belau's answer
makes you wonder if getting married was
the best choice for them
we've been apart for so long i'm like
let's enjoy each other for a little bit
yeah how long has a little bit like uh
you know two years
two years she's gonna be 39. you should
remember the time you don't control time
yeah but you never know how long after
you really start trying it'll take thank
you they put in the prenup to try to
have a baby before she turns 40.
but pushing it to the last minute
it can come off as if he's okay with
lowering the chances of them having a
baby although he knows it's something
his wife really wants
that doesn't seem fair because now it
feels like shada's somewhat locked in
this relationship
you know what for the next two years she
has to live with the anxiety of time
possibly running out
just have the baby
wait i don't know they got so much to
work through
this is hard
i am in a pickle bella thinks having a
baby life stops no i don't i don't think
that you're you're taking my the context
that i'm saying differently what i am
saying is when you do have children the
reality is is that it limits you on some
things you can do at that moment i feel
like when you meet the right person you
know that's what i said to him when we
first started talking not against me
because i say that when we first started
talking she mentioned she didn't have
children i actually convinced her to
help children because i do want more
children you know but is that true he
convinced you to have
children it didn't happen like that
whatsoever
as a tell-all raps jabri doubles down on
his opinion that they are not going to
make it
uh benny and ari are very toxic uh bilal
and cheetah are also
toxic and as everyone is packing up to
go home
kobe and emily stop by shada and bilal's
room
to try to give them some encouragement
i just wanted to say i don't think it
was fair that jabrie said
you guys won't last i think you guys
will for sure last
and i see love and chemistry and
i felt really bad i'm sorry that i
didn't say anything in the moment i
regret that i regret not standing up
everybody
has ups and downs and
it's so sad that somebody not in your
shoe
is predicting what your relationship is
going to look like
but i mean you guys are the ones in need
and you definitely know it's going to
work you're not sure enough you know the
baby i mean i don't care what people say
about us but i know we doing good below
tries to keep up his smile but you can
see that this tell-all has shaken him to
his core
he's gone from lecturing to a man of few
words
it's obvious that it hurts chyda to see
her husband down and she does make it
clear that he isn't only his flaws i do
know bilal is an amazing person like i
will not travel all this way almost 3
000 miles to marry someone that i think
is not fit to be a husband
it's these little things that get into a
relationship if we don't deal with it
now i could fester and when i look at
after hearing shahidah it looked like
they never dealt with that and it
probably reached that point where she
was like oh i can't take it anymore at
the same time she also makes it clear
that if not worked on
those flaws can ruin them
so now i want us to not make that same
mistake that's all
we identify what is the problem and we
can work on it and listen i'm willing to
work on it as your wife i'm here with
you
but if i stay silent it could turn out
to be like your last marriage
[Music]
wow
shy
i hope they can figure this all out i
wish them the best
okay that is a wrap for season 9 of 90
day fiance
who was your favorite on nutella
mine was definitely kobe he was speaking
truth on that stage
there's a saying that like 90 of the
problems in the world is not the
difference of opinion but the tone used
you should remember the time you don't
control time you made a number of good
points y'all know he does motivational
videos on his social media
there's somebody breathing their last
breath out there right now they wish
they had more time to live on earth to
change one or two things but they don't
have that you are alive
it's a blessing not everybody's
privileged to have you have the
opportunity to reshape your life while
you were wrong yesterday
you can change it today it's dope i was
like look at kobe
check it out
all right 90 day fans fam i enjoyed my
time with you this season
it's been a unique one that's for sure
but as always i appreciate you next week
fan favorites are back on happily ever
after hi michael
happy birthday
you're out of his league
i think if we didn't have milo we'd
probably be divorced already i mean
first zip lining can now kamasutra
you're gonna propose to him i wanna do
it are you serious
love is not enough to make a
relationship work
happily ever after premieres next sunday
at 8 on tlc
make sure you stick with e.t because we
are covering it all
i'll see you next time
[Music]